[Music]  so FC what do you do I work for Kingsman  the tailless - I must say you are really  not as I expected  yes look about  welcome to statement independent  intelligence agency your American cousin  how can I help it if I say the world  situation here  say goodbye to the Kingsmen the follow  the Doomsday protocol let's get started  you gotta make you wanna slap your mama  right there bored brains skills  skipping rope it's a lasso whatever  we're from the Kingsmen tailor shop in  London maybe you've heard of us  today marks the beginning of a new age  but I'm gonna show you to the Kingsmen  chronicle a bit of a save the world  situation here  welcome to Statesman did your American  cousins will be working side by side  let's get started  we've got brains skills skipping-rope  [Music]  - lasso whatever  [Music]  it's very American yeah it is  [Music]  manners maketh man do you know what that  means  [Music]